mike yostrimski will walk up to the
plate get ready to hit from the left
side against the 23 year old left-hander
julio aureus and yostrepski hammers one
to right field mookie bets over toward
the corner and right where the grass and
warning track meet mookie hauls it in
for out number one a sharp line drive
off the bat of yoshremski results in out
number one two down and the batter is
hunter patch giants with a runner at
first
he hits one up in the air right center
field drifting over is cody ballinger
moki betz backs off bellinger reaches up
makes the catch
and the top of the first is over who
runs a hit the dodgers will come up
against the giants left-hander drew
smiley we saw him in relief on thursday
but tonight he makes his first giant
start so that keeps the ending going for
cody bellinger last year's national
league mvp
her boss swung on and hit high in the
air to right but two steps back and now
moving in a little bit jalen davis he's
got it
the inning is over so the giants with a
base runner jalen davis right-handed
hitting right fielder
strike three call with the runner going
the throw down to second and he is
called safe a one-hop throw by will
smith heinemann went in with a head
first dive so a runner in scoring
position now for crawford crawford swing
and it's a hard ground ball to the
backhand side of the shortstop seeger
the throw to first is in the dirt but
scooped out with a backhand swipe of the
glove by muncie the inning is over here
is [ __ ] hernandez
fastball there's a high fly ball in the
left center racing over to his left
yostremski does not get there and dubon
just let him try to take it i don't know
if he has thought that maybe dubon was
going to take charge on it because
that's what you expect from a center
fielder
face it for kiki stretched by smiley
here comes the 2-1 to
aj paula and aj swings hits the ground
ball right to the middle but waiting for
it was wilmer flores in the second
baseman passes forward steps on the bag
and gets the force out of her name there
two on one out
and darren ruff coming up well now that
dreaded two-strike scenario against
urias where he can be so tough he throws
and ruff kind of gets jammed but he
muscles one a low liner past the reach
of seeger into left field taylor up with
the ball his throw home is too late
dubon's gonna score standing darren ruff
knocks in a run the giants have a one
nothing lead
now mookie bets becomes a big problem
because he is one of the best base
runners in the game there goes mook a
good jump heinemann won't even make a
throw head first dive and safe with a
stolen base the first one is a dodger
this is played right into the dodgers
hands down with two runners aboard and
their biggest power and threat due up
swung on and that is drilled on the
ground in the right field of basic bench
touches third he's on his way home and
the dodgers have tied it bellinger
didn't wait around first ball swinging
then a rocket on the ground past wilmer
flores and the game is tied at one and
the go-ahead run is in scoring position
and he delivers and he strikes him out
looking
fastball belt high
now justin turner the right adjective
with a runner at second two down turner
has singled
and walked bounding ball left side of
the infield charging is crawford he
double clutches throws to first and he
gets turner by a step the dodgers leave
the go ahead run out there one to one
here in the sixth now mauricio dubon who
got his first hit of the year swinging
there's a line drive in the left field
base hit racing around third to solano
heading home here comes the throw it's
cut off solano scores and that is the
hit that dubon has been waiting for and
it came at a great moment the giants are
back ahead so here's seeger left-handed
hitter with power flight out deep to
center and grounded out to second seeger
into the other corner
boy that chased rough and he made the
catch and opened up the bullpen gate at
the same time he's a big guy i mean yeah
fence lost that match right there man
that's a strong boy
it's a second career steal for darren
ruff face it could add to the giants
lead solano swings and lines one into
left field that is a base hit here comes
ruff around third taylor up with the
ball he's not even going to make a throw
darren ruff will score and his legs help
get the giants an extra run it's three
to one giants here in the top of the
seven a huge battle here a base hit to
the outfield could tie the game rory
seeger hit by the pitch and now the
bases oh wait a minute it hit the back
looked like it hit him on the hand so
this would be looked at it looked like
it was heading right for his wrist but
it never touches his wrist and hits the
knob and they're going to put them on
well again when you're looking at replay
has to be convincing dodgers threatening
in the bottom of the eighth tying runs
in scoring position go ahead run is on
pk hernandez one for three tonight the
swing there's a ground ball to third
couple of big hops fielded and thrown
across the diamond by solano in plenty
of time for the out and the inning is
over so it's up to max muncie who's over
four
got ready kicks throws he's struck about
swinging and the giants have won it and
they salvaged they split in the series
[Applause]